les plus un secret pour personne la
plupart des routes en france sont
limitées en voici un exemple en vache
qui est moins évident c'est le cas que
les automobilistes font de cette
limitation de vitesse alors pour vous en
rendre compte que nous sommes livrés à
une expérience fort simple nous avons
nous mêmes à bord d'une automobile
respecter cette limitation de vitesse
vous allez voir que les autres
automobilistes n'ont pas fait tous comme
nous
sur cette portion d'autoroute où la
vitesse est limitée à 80 kilomètres
heure en raison de travaux la plupart
des automobiles nous doublent à plus de
100 km
il semble que le seul remède contre
l'excès de vitesse soit la peur choisi
ancestrale du gendarme pour peu que sa
silhouette se profile à l'horizon les
stops des voitures salut
comme quoi l'on ne doit pas trop faire
confiance au sens de la responsabilité
du conducteur
il y a pourtant au moins deux raisons
indiscutable de respecter la limitation
de vitesse les vitesses que l'on indique
c'est parfait comme ça ça corresponde
chose de précis ça correspond un rayon
de courbure ça correspond à une distance
de civilisation ça correspond à la
longueur d'une bande jaune par exemple
des fêtes vous reconnais que ça nous
échapperons jeudi mais enfin bon là on
pour aller plus vite
non c'est bien fait alors au fond si
vous allez au delà et bien votre vitesse
ne correspond plus aux distances prévu
vous avez vous trouvé trop vite sur une
demande continue
vous avez vous trouvé premier d'un
croisement vous à dire rouspéteur disant
mais qu'est ce qu'ils font on est pas
produit assez tôt ben non c'est parce
que votre vie ne correspond pas il faut
vraiment respecté ce qui est fait comme
dans l'aviation on a des vies tests
approchent de terry sage comme ma le
chemin de fer qu'en cessant ses 130 140
et ils vont le faire
ya l'aspect inverse aussi un petit peu
sur certaines routes on voit des
panneaux par exemple imitation à 120 les
gens croient qu'ils peuvent rouler à 120
alors on n'a jamais dit ça on a dit que
si la vitesse maxi est que dépassée mais
s'il ya du brouillard de la grêle s'il
ya la queue sous est fatigué pour les
moines y c'est la vitesse maxi vouloir
se met alors à cette époque de retour de
vacances lorsque commence à rouler dur
moi j'ai une raisons de respect de la
vitesse qui est qui est toute bête qui
est très simple c'est encore
actuellement le meilleur moyen de garde
les permis de conduire parce que y'a
quand même un contrôle
j'ai vraiment sévère ou pas que ça vire
sévère ça veut dire que la piste
nationale et la gendarmerie font des
contrôles indiscutable avec des
cinémomètres et que moi je sais que ça
se multiplient et que c'est très très
embêtant c'est embêtant et arrêté
laissant btan de payer entre 100 et 300
francs de recevoir voir un avertissement
avoir un petit retrait tombe est temps
de rentrer chez soi c'est bien au top
sans permis de conduire là c'est une
raison bien bien bête mais moi je crois
qu'il faut respecter la limitation de
vitesse les limites à la limitation en
ville en particulier